Tyra Banks is returning as host of
America's Next Top Model
exactly it's next level the supermodel
and a vh1 the series new network
announced the decision Thursday in a
statement to ET quote Tyra has always
been the heart and soul of the franchise
and her absence was deeply felt by our
fiercely loyal fans who missed their
queen of this minds and these photos
represent the three of you that will
still be in the running towards becoming
America's next top Tyra hosted the first
22 seasons of the show but left when the
series left the CW I'd like to do things
and leave went on top this means the
supermodel will be pulling double
hosting duty in 2017 both an TM and
America's Got Talent which she's taking
over from Nick Cannon models welcome
back it also means cycle 23 host Rita
Ora is officially out at Top Model even
though she told ET she was in for the
next season
just last month you're hosting America's
Next Top Model and I understand there's
going to be a season two yes there is
tell us about that well I'll tell you
this it's gonna be based in LA in
judging panel from what I know of right
now it's the same judging panel
you